[Music]
can we just talk about the smack game of
chess come for you on point
thank you organizers who doing a Grinch
up also Malta's dance party but playing
in the background amazing killing it
okay I want all of you to get pumped
right now because the journey we're
going to go on is going to blow your
minds we're going to talk about
something I've been obsessed with
recently which is sequential art comics
and SPG's my name is Laura the job on
the internet I work at a puzzle Digital
group I'm an engineer Russell is a
feminist publication for millennial
women with an emphasis on inclusivity
positivity and empowerment what I love
about working in media and publishing is
that as an engineer I get to be a
digital storyteller
I guess self stories that become
relevant on an emotional as well as an
intellectual level one of the things
that we pride ourselves on at bustled is
breaking out of the standard article
format for example one of the story
selling formats that we've experimented
with is this interactive flow chart it's
a choose-your-own-adventure format that
breaks you out of the monotony of just
reading an article and forces you to
make decisions and things differently
than you would otherwise it tells you a
story and walks you through the journey
giving you clues along the way and I
think the best way to convey something
is to tell a story whether that's
educating entertaining or persuading and
once and when we think about the web
there's so many different ways where in
our daily lives we tell each other
stories whether that's through movies
photographs or tweets
and what all of these have in common is
that they break the story into pieces
arranged in a very specific way for you
move sequentially through time one of
the best known forms of selling stories
in a sequential format that predates the
internet and the moving image is of
course comics Will Eisner the master
comic uses the term sequential art when
describing comics and Scott McCloud was
a brilliant comic book artist get some
stats about the different forms of
sequential art in his book understanding
comics Scott McCloud has a beautiful
example of what will eisner is talking
about when he refers to sequential art
he says were taken individually the
pictures on the left are just pictures
but when they become part of a sequence
even if that sequence is only to the art
of the image is transformed into the art
of comics he goes on further to define
what we talk about when we talk about
comics he says juxtaposed with pictorial
and other images in deliberate sequence
intended to convey information and/or to
produce aesthetic response from the
viewer comics that have been around for
a very long time in fact they predate
the internet by centuries here's a comic
from 32 centuries ago for the tomb of
Menna an ancient Egyptian scribe and
what's interesting about this comic is
that the Egyptians read their comics a
zigzag and then on the other side of the
world archeologists have discovered
ancient paintings in Mexico scada 2700
years later organized similarly even
though this doesn't look like a modern
comic what we're looking at is so story
told in a deliberate chronological order
where you start on the bottom left and
end on the top right there are no panel
borders like were used to but there are
so clear divisions of scenes now I have
no idea when or where the first comic
was created in history but the one
invention that is heat was a huge to go
in the history of comics and sequential
art is in mention of printing printing
fare to turn the art form that has been
a diversion for the wrists
the powerful and allowed it to be
enjoyed by everyone so given the long
legacy of comics and as an art form and
given that print change comics how does
the internet then change our
relationship to sequential art and what
does it mean for us to go from print
comics to post print comics as in comics
in the digital age for us above all one
of the first steps we took into post
print comics was an animated Instagram
story three is called Sunday comics
which makes the visuals of comics with
sound motion and interactivity we
produced these once a week sometimes
there were a series pulled over a span
of a few weeks and sometimes there was
just one up they were super fun to make
is fun to watch which then made us
wonder how can we take this further how
do we push the boundaries of the browser
and bring a similar experience to the
web without making them difficult to
produce we didn't want to just adopt the
shape of the previous technology of
print comics that we were already
acquainted with for example you could
just draw a comic scan it in into an
article and then say that you brought
comics to the web but to me that's not
very interesting I wanted to take my
learnings from the ancient comics where
there's a single unbroken reading line
while taking advantage of all the things
that the browser has to offer so I set
out to create stories in the form of
sequential art and an infinite canvas
along the y-axis so this is the comic
experience we both in its final form we
wanted to recontextualize sequential art
and the unique capabilities of the
browser while emotionally engaging the
audience for example notice that there's
this interesting parallax effect where
things that are closer to scroll more
quickly than things that are in the
background everything is full screen to
take advantage of the beautiful Retina
displays where you can see all this
incredible detail and then you move the
mouse things move around with you and
you can change your perspective within
the frame
it gets the viewer involved and you have
to interact with it to see to see
everything in its full glory sometimes
you even have to move it around to see
the text if you're on the laptop or your
phone if you can go to bustled comm
splash comics right now and check it out
on yourself or check it out by yourself
while I'm climbing q so how do we do
this and of course the answer is the
solutions to most things on the web I'm
just kidding there's zero react symbols
it's SVG it's not on-brand
reactors not on-brand okay so those
videos are a good tool to have and use
specially for storytelling because
they're resolution-independent
so they're sharp on any display which
means you don't have to do any image
replacement for different resolutions
and of course they're easily scalable
for responsive designs so you don't have
to produce a bunch of different assets
with different screens and they're super
easy to animate which makes them the
most fun the fact lettuce videos allow
us to create these incredibly rich
narratives of mind-blowing they're truly
one of the coolest things you can play
around with as a developer so how is
this built the first step was to get the
parallax working and if you're thinking
to yourself why parallax first of all
why not and second of all is because
showing static web content can be boring
parallax adds depth to the scene and
creates a sense of physicality when
appropriate why not let your visitor
interact with your site and explore
things on their own initiative
instead of using static images you get a
3d presentation controlled by your own
scrolling if given the chance why not
use the opportunity to tell stories in
an engaging and interactive way in
practice instead of calculating the
parallax movement in JavaScript we
challenge yourself to do as much in CSS
as possible
shout out to CSS comm for you
to create the parallax effects in pure
CSS we have to move into 3d space by
using 3d transforms to activate 3d space
an element needs to be given the
prospective CSS property which then and
there enables 3d space for it style
elements so you define the height and
the perspective style properties of the
parent element and that will lock the
perspective fits Center creating a 3d
viewport with a fixed origin the
scrolling speed of the parallax elements
is achieved by applying the translate Z
function to the transform property of
the child elements which places the
elements along the z axis by moving them
farther away or closer to the user
after experimentation we take the
maximum distance distance to be the
background layer the last layer said
that this sits at that distance and we
evenly distribute the remaining layers
from crackdowns for foreground and
here's what it looks like in Illustrator
where there are seven layers and those
layers are distributed evenly between
the foreground and the background
because we're using perspectives to
achieve the parallax movement effect
when we move things farther along the
z-axis they're naturally going to get
smaller but the illustrators have
already drawn their comics to scale
which makes this behavior inappropriate
so we need to do some depth correction
we need to apply a scale transform to
the elements as appears to be render
that it's the original size on the Left
we have the scale transform applied vs.
on the right there is no scale transform
the good news is that things move
farther away they get smaller at a
predictable rate so we can apply a scale
transform to render it at its original
size this way we get the parallax
effects of moving things along the z
axis without the size distortions the
advantage of is is that we just set a
few CSS properties and the browser takes
care of everything else and there's very
minimal JavaScript required to set up
the comic so again this is how the scene
will look with and without depth
correction so on the right we can see
what happens when we translate things
on the z-axis without applying scale and
on the right is the DEF correction with
the scale applied for example the
farther back in the scene in the element
is we're going to apply a larger V
translation to it but it also means that
we're going to apply a larger scale
factor to compensate now even though
this seems like fun and games and
browser support is generally excellent
for refugees it's a whole other story
when you apply CSS transforms to them
this is especially painful when it comes
to animations because scale position
rotation and scale front that's so
fundamental when you apply transforms to
an element inside the SVG their browser
bugs and inconsistencies this gift is
from an excellent article in CSS tricks
which shows how different the same
animation looks on different browsers ie
in Opera don't honor CSS transforms at
all on SVG elements instead you must
assign the value to the transform
attribute we could use tools like green
sock animation platform to make it work
but then what's the fun in using a
third-party library instead of figuring
out how to do it on your own so our
solution was to explode the SVG where
each layer in the SVG because it becomes
an SVG element of its own and this
allows us to apply our CSS transform
reliably across all browsers here's what
the SVG looks like an illustrator with
SiC layer six layers making up the scene
on the right and then on the Left we
have that same SVG with each of those
six layers exploded into their own SVG
elements and they're all stacked on top
of each other to make it look like the
original another cool thing about these
comics is the movement in them as you
move your mouse or your phone everything
moves with you the closer the layer is
to you the more it moves and the further
away it is it moves less and less just
like in real world things that are
closest to us move faster than this
things that are farther away this is one
of the constraints we wanted to add
we didn't want the designers to think
about how to animate each movement and
to just have it done for them
automatically based on a number of
layers they use what's cool is the
effect that gives it gives you a sense
of being in the scene and as an anecdote
the designer started putting things in
their illustrations or you have to
interact with it to suit what's going on
in the whole story so how did we manage
to get the pages to respond to the mass
and desire scope movement with the help
of our good friend from our math days
logarithmic scale which is a nonlinear
scale used when there is a large range
of quantities earthquakes prints for
example which is not unlike shaking your
phone or moving your mouse in the
digital world so here's the guy that
mass movement on a linear scale like the
mouse moving on a logarithmic scale that
we use to actually transform each layer
and then you apply the shift to an event
listener based on device orientation or
mouse movement as a visual example of
how log scale works as the mouse moves
in the center the layers move quite a
bit but as you get closer to the edges
of the browser they move less and less
because you don't want things to fly off
the screen again just like in an
earthquake
what's also cool is that you have to
move your mouse around to see what's in
the mirror or what's in the background
and behind the window on the left an
important goal of this project was to
allow our designers to be productive in
the tools they already know one of the
reasons for using SVG is that our
designers already know how to make them
in a program they use day in and day out
Adobe Illustrator one thing we could
have done was spend half a year building
an online comics editor what a dhobi has
already done that for us by creating
illustrator and our designers already
know how to use them and one of the
coolest parts of this for me personally
is that even though they have the same
tools and constraints they each have
completely different processes for how
they design Allison Gore for example
storyboards the entire comic she starts
with a loose plan figures out how the
panels are set up and relate to each
other and then move on to illustrate
and deconstruct the layers to figure out
how their interaction works these are
some examples were for work it's cool to
see the behind the scenes Austin
sometimes draws out his main characters
on paper and then moves into Illustrator
to draw out the whole scene and
interesting thing about Austin's work is
he uses a lot of color and when I asked
him about it he said it's because he's
from New Orleans and when he grew up
surrounded by beautiful colors and since
he'd moved to New York City he misses
the color for how colorful things are
and so he's tries to remind himself of
home in his work Alyssa draws out her
character is an on paper and tries to
get them to their simplest form in order
to create more iconic moments she also
dries out pieces of the scene on paper
and writes herself lots of notes before
moving on to drawing at the scene in
Illustrator she draws Lance and reminds
himself this is what the Netflix logo
looks like or this is what my table
should look like it was also believed
that it's best to give the audience
who's without drying out every single
detail for them and letting them figure
things out and put pieces together on
their own she believes minimum
minimalism goes a long way when it comes
to comics Don draws out some of parts of
the story and tries to make sense of the
story before doing anything else and
sometimes end up ends up working with
the writer more closely to change the
story entirely they fund her first
impressions of what did not making sense
once put into drawing she tries to
figure out the characters emotions on
paper rather than details she also feels
like she's playing God while trying to
figure out what the plays in the
background or what does the character
look like or what does the room look
like or what color is their hair Mary
figures out the basics of each panel on
paper but one of the interesting things
about her process is that she likes to
draw it
her main character with different
emotions and from different viewpoints
before she starts laying things out it
was very rewarding to work on these
things because for relatively little
engineering works
we can the help designers save these
experiences that they've never made
before and that our viewers have never
seen before
I'm personally a huge fan of the theory
of meeting your audience through
designers in your collaborate is where
they are today and so the most important
lesson I want you to take away from this
talk is meet your users where they are I
know we all have instincts to rewrite
everything and create all these new
tools but it's really really important
to think about how to leverage existing
tools and as Fugees are in a perfect
example of that
you probably are already worthless
designers they already know illustrator
what are some ideas that you have that
you if you were able to get out of SPG's
what would you do I showed you two
examples here with interactive
flowcharts and comics both of these have
super simple rules that the designers
can follow so you're out your layers
export to SVG done it's also important
to note that setting constraints is okay
some of the designers were definitely a
little hesitant about not having enough
control over the animation or the depth
or the movement or wanting to be able to
animate certain things differently but
the answer I always gave was the same as
sure I'm sure some of you have given
once or twice PRS are welcome but all
joking aside I think having constraints
and having to work within limits creates
more opportunity for creativity and
innovation the way they're using
parallax and pants the story in these
two examples is mind blowing
and again it's been super rewarding
being a part of it so the question I
have for all of us is what are other
things we can do by exploring and using
illustrator as a development tool almost
or are there more file formats are there
other tools people wrap people around
this already know that we can use the
power of JavaScript to parse analyze and
augment no no thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my office music